[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans l'émission
point de vue je vous présente nos deux
invités qui ont accepté de participer ce
soir guillaume bernard bonsoir maître de
conférence de l'institut catholique
d'études supérieures de vendée et
ferghana ziari bonsoir bienvenue à vous
êtes chargé d'études à l'iref l'institut
de recherches économiques et fiscales
alors aujourd'hui on va aborder deux
thèmes un d'une grande actualité depuis
plusieurs jours depuis notamment les
annonces des manuels macron et on va
s'intéresser à la culture faut-il une
exception culturelle la culture
doit-elle déroger au couvre-feu et le
deuxième thème qui nous est imposée
depuis le début de l'après midi c'est la
mise en examen de nicolas sarkozy dans
l'affairé libyenne et du coup on se
posera cette question est ce qu'il y à
un acharnement judiciaire contre nicolas
sarkozy
premier thème donc faut-il une exception
culturelle au couvre feu c'est la
demande un peu des professionnels de la
culture des patrons des salles de
spectacles qui était relayé par la
ministre de la culture roselyne bachelot
et justement écouté ce matin
ladreit de lacharrière monsieur ladreit
de lacharrière qui est propriétaire de
plusieurs salles à paris et qui est
intervenu sur europe 1 in bachelot est
pour moi une guerrière
ces guerriers guerrière elle avait tout
cas l'avantagé une sacrée bataille là où
elle a toujours montré une force de
conviction très forte tel m
défendez noble cause des vraies causes
et je fais très confiance en à cette
guerrière ont pour arriver au résultat
parce que dans la réalité vous voyez
bien que 12 ce que nous demandons pour
l'instant c'est quelque chose
relativement sommes nous aurions préféré
naturellement 22 heures mais nous
préférons que les gens puissent partir
du spectacle à 21h
alors en écho à ce propos il ya la vidéo
de fabrice luchini qu'il a postés sur
les réseaux sociaux et qui a été vue par
des centaines de milliers de personnes
et je vous propose d'écouter un petit
extrait on vit on ne comprend pas c'est
ça qui est terrifiant c'est qu'on ne
comprend pas ce que ce gouvernement fait
la panique de vers en la lal l'accent
qui cède 1,2 castex c'est terrifiant
c'est morbide c'est sordide
on n'a plus envie demis gouvernement ni
rien à bientôt
moi je joue à 18h30 et je vais essayer
de mettre les écrivains soit le dimanche
midi ou soit le lundi à 18h30
bonne journée alors ferghana ziari vous
vous comprenez cette inquiétude du monde
de la culture où vous vous dites assez
des enfants gâtés pourquoi eux plutôt
que d'autres seraient exemptés non je
comprends cette inquiétude maintenant
moi j'ai retrouvé beaucoup plus loin
c'est à dire que avant de se demander
s'il faut faire une exception pour ce
secteur en particulier moi j'aimerais
qu'on s'attarde beaucoup plus sur le
bien fondé de ce couvre-feu de ces
mesures restrictives en tant que tel
c'est à dire que je pense que nous
payons depuis le début de cette pandémie
une opposition veines et stupide entre
d'un côté la santé l'économie c'est la
doctrine officielle depuis le début on
oppose on nous dit que la santé doit
primer sur l'économie pour ma part j'ai
toujours sauver les hôpitaux sauver des
services oui mais je pense que cette
opposition santé et économie
elle a toujours été stupide pour une
raison très simple c'est que je ne
connais pas pour ma part une nation dont
la santé ne soit pas subordonnée d'une
manière ou d'une autre à sa richesse
c'est à dire que si on afrique
subsaharienne on a une espérance de vie
inférieure à celle de l'europe c'est
parce qu'on est plus pauvres même en
france on sait très bien que par exemple
les 5% les plus riches des français
vivent en moyenne 13 ans de plus que les
5 % les plus pauvres céline c'est qu'il
le dit pourquoi parce que la richesse la
liberté de travailler de subvenir à ses
besoins conditionne l'accès à une
multitude de services comme bien
s'alimenter accéder à des médicaments et
des vaccins donc une multitude de
services qui qui
on traite simplement aux conditions
sanitaires des populations
quand j'ai vu rob allemand ce que vous
dites ce qu'il faudrait pas de couvre
feu mais oui parce que c'est je
regardais ya pas longtemps les chiffres
de l'onu qui disait que notre aide c'est
à dire que la crise économique provoquée
par toutes ces mesures restrictives que
l'on prend depuis des mois risque de
plonger plus de 490 millions de gens
dans ce qu'ils appellent eux une
pauvreté multidimensionnelle
donc moi je pose la question combien
d'années de vie va t'on ôter à ceux qui
auront replonger dans l'indigence par
ces mesures restrictives alors
généralement quand je quand je j'emploie
cet argument on aurait tort toujours
mais on n'en sait rien et je trouve cet
argument assez incroyable c'est à dire
que nous vivons depuis 20 ans où l'
empire du principe de précaution qui
nous dit que toute décision doit être
prise grâce à un calcul coûts bénéfices
il y avait des certitudes or aujourd'hui
je n'ai pas vu le la moindre étude
d'impact il ya la moindre assertion qui
nous permettrait de vérifier que les
mesures que l'on prend sur le plan
sanitaire et autres et bien soit tout
simplement bénédicte que le bénéfice
apporté soit supérieur aux mâles
qu'induisent ces mesures guillaume
bernard si on revient sur l'aspect
proprement exception culturelle
vous êtes favorable à cette exception
culturelle pour les salles de théâtre
les salles de cinéma la salle de
spectacle alors je vais faire un petit
détour mais c'est promis je réponds à la
question s'il vous plaît de manière
générale je ne suis absolument pas
opposé et choqué par le fait qu'il y ait
des traitements différenciés
quand il ya des situations différentes
donc effectivement en fonction des
activités il puisse y avoir des
traitements différents qu'en fonction
des lieux il puisse y avoir des
traitements différents
ça me paraît parfaitement ce qui est le
cas de la stratégie du
du gouvernement puisque territorialement
par exemple le vaut brevet ne s'applique
pas ne s'applique pas par simple donc
c'est avant cela moi ça ne me ça ça ne
me serait pas après pardon mais je crois
que effectivement il faut en revenir à
ce que fergane disait c'est à dire que
et c'est la légitimité même du couvre
feu et la délimitation établi à 21
heures qui est évidemment susceptibles
d'être discutés d'être aidé être
contestées alors je vous propose c'est
d'écouter jean castex qui a répondu tout
à l'heure à lille à la ministre de la
culture et à la dri ladreit de
lacharrière et fabrice luchini écoutez
pour que des règles soient comprises
pour que des règles soient acceptées il
faut qu'elles soient les mêmes pour tous
s'agissant du secteur de la culture j'y
reviens impactés par ces dispositions
nous déploierons tous les moyens tous
les moyens nous l'avons indiqué
également hier pour amortir le choc que
cela va représenter
pour lui les discussions continuent à
cet effet je suis sûr je l'entends du
d'ailleurs que ce secteur va aussi
s'adapter à ces règles du jeu mais
encore une fois il est clair il faut que
les règles soient les mêmes pour tout le
monde
vous avez esquiver la réponse à la
question sur la culture donc je reviens
vers vous je veux ma réponse il a raison
le premier ministre ou pas je pense que
qu'il faille des règles adaptées pour
pour qu'il faille les mêmes règles pour
tous oui pourquoi pas mais moi j'aurais
voulu que cette égalité soit l'égalité
de la liberté ici ce n'est pas le cas
maintenant c'est vrai que se pose la
question aussi de la subsidiarité c'est
à dire je pense qu'on paie aussi le
manque de confiance à l'égard de
l'industrie de la culture sa capacité à
s'adapter mois les quelques fois où je
suis allé au cinéma au théâtre ces
derniers temps j'ai pu quand même
observer des protocoles sanitaires très
strictes très rigoureux avec des espaces
de l'espace laissé entre les spectateurs
une obligation de porter un masque une
discipline aussi observé chez chez la
clientèle donc moi je ne comprends pas
qu'on fasse pas davantage confiance aux
français de manière générale il s'agit
des français qui travaillent dans
l'industrie de la culture mais aussi des
autres français et je m'étonne aussi
qu'on soit aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
prompte à anéantir les libertés
publiques à demander des comptes à ceux
qui en réalité n'ont pas su adapter nos
capacités hospitalières puisque faut-il
le rappeler l'unique critère aujourd'hui
de la politique sanitaire c'est
l'engorgement des hôpitaux
or aujourd'hui on est beaucoup plus
pressé de d'anéantir les libertés
publiques des français que d'interroger
finalement cette incapacité de la
bureaucratie sanitaire à adapter son
offre à la demande
alors on nous dit qu'on ne peut pas
former des médecins des infirmiers
en trois mois j'entends cet argument a
simplement il faut aussi regarder là où
les marges de manoeuvre sont possibles
prenez l'exemple de l'italie par exemple
en quelques mois ils ont embauché
environ 6000 infirmiers pardon signé le
médecin et 14001 fermi en quelques mois
comment ont-ils fait ils ont fait preuve
d'agilité
ils ont accéléré la certification des
étudiants c'est à dire que des étudiants
en médecine qui aurait dû terminer leurs
études leurs études l'année prochaine se
sont finalement retrouvés propulsés au
rang au rang de médecins n'est-il pas là
encore en france ddd leviers à actionner
en propulsant des externes hors en
interne plus rapidement pour augmenter
ses capacités hospitalières en temps de
guerre est ce qu'il faut pas des mesures
exceptionnelles pour faire face à la
pandémie tout en préservant au maximum
mais il a été fondamental mais guillaume
bernard est ce que vous n'avez pas
l'impression va qui a pas un risque que
ce couvre-feu ce confinement nocturne
soit fatal au théâtre au cinéma parce
que on leur en mai on leur dit rouvrez
vite
accueillez vite du monde ils s'adaptent
ils mettent faire gagner rillaer elle a
rappelé des protocoles très très sévère
qui le font perdre des recettes puisque
pour le coup c'est quasiment un fauteuil
chose sur deux qui est vide et là on
leur dit pas non maintenant le soir vous
allez fermer c'est vraiment le tout le
monde de la culture qui est menacée plus
compact c'est que ce soit que le monde
de la culture c'est aussi quand même
tout un ensemble de commerces sur les
restaurants les bistrots nos chers
bistro français
et puis outre le fait que c'est un pan
d'activité qui va être effectivement
sinistrés on nous explique que on va
essayer de les sauver par le biais de
subventions
c'est à dire qu'en fait ce sont les
contribuables ils vont devoir et bien
essayé de compenser deux ils
n'arriveront jamais à les compenser
suffisamment est intégralement donc ce
qui fait que de toute façon ces
entreprises vont se retrouver en
difficulté
mais en août le contribuable peut se
retrouver encore plus taxés sincèrement
un jeu économie s'effondre il ya
incontestablement un risque
effectivement de dépression économique
extrêmement grave et je crois qu'il faut
revenir sur ce que ferghana dit tout à
l'heure c'est à dire que l'état veut
assurer une sécurité au détriment des
libertés
alors je sais bien que c'est toute la
logique du contrat social auquel
personnellement je ne crois absolument
pas n'importe lesquels l'abandon des
libertés pour avoir obtenir un minimum
de sécurité
ça me paraît ubuesque et et non
acceptable alors vous abordé non mais on
essaiera de prendre à coeur du sujet et
de ce que nous pose comme question les
internautes christophe qui dit si le
couvre-feu ne sert à rien et que les
hospitalisations continue on fait quoi
et les autres questions de 6 ch est-ce
que ce couvre-feu est suffisamment
efficace pour justifier la description
la destruction des commerces
on est au coeur du c'est une très bonne
question mais encore une fois je
regrette qu'il n'y ait pas eu d'étude
d'impact c'est à dire qu'encore une fois
l'eau le calcul coût bénéfice de cette
mesure extrêmement autoritaire n'a pas
été fait tout simplement
et donc on peut difficilement validé une
telle mesure sans ce calcul coûts
bénéfices d'autant plus que moi je suis
assez étonné que que personne ne met le
doigt sur un problème fondamental qui
occultait depuis le début de cette
pandémie
qu'est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on
n'arrive pas à avoir une offre en
adéquation avec la demande s'est
notamment le manque de personnel c'est à
dire que jean castex lalart expliqué
lors de sa conférence de presse il ya
deux jours en dix ans j'entends beaucoup
j'entends dire qu'il faudra augmenter
les lits de réanimation mes enfants
vivent plusieurs stars mais mais là
encore qui depuis des décennies impose
au secteur de la santé un numerus
clausus complètement débile qui a
complètement désarmé le pays en matière
de professions de santé
est-ce qu'on va demander des comptes à
des gens qui ont fabriqué depuis 40 ans
de la pénurie en limitant
artificiellement le nombre de médecins
et de professions de santé qui peuvent
être formés sur le territoire français
est-ce qu'on va apprendre de nos erreurs
et mettre fin à ces restrictions
malthusienne et corporatistes qui ont
pour le coup contribuer à mettre en jeu
notre sécurité sanitaire pour un
bénéfice économique nulle complètement
nul alors nous avons des commission
denquête et la justice qui est saisie
peut-être plus sur les masques sur ces
aspects là mais on aura peut-être des
réponses
en tout cas il ya des réponses qui sont
arrivés à notre question faut-il faire
des dérogations après 21h pour continuer
à aller au cinéma et dans les salles de
spectacles et bien les internautes sont
comme vous n'ont 61% considèrent qu' il
faut pas forcément faire de dérogation
pour continuer à aller au cinéma
oui si ce n'est que nous notre position
pour le coup nous sommes d'accord c'est
de considérer que la barre de 21h et
inacceptable aurait mieux fallu il
aurait mieux fallu car vous n'êtes pas
mettre du tout d'heure exactement alors
on va voir si vous êtes d'accord sur le
deuxième sujet
la justice s'acharne tel contre nicolas
sarkozy on l'a appris en en fin de
matinée nicolas sarkozy l'ancien
président de la république a été mis en
examen dans la sphère du financement
supposé par la libye de sa campagne
présidentielle de 2007
mis en examen pour association de
malfaiteurs donc ça fait déjà lourd
puisqu'il a déjà deux rendez-vous avec
la justice dans les mois qui viennent le
23 novembre pour la faire bismuth
azibert dans laquelle il est mis en
examen pour corruption et trafic
d'influencé
et à partir du 17 mars prochain pour la
faire bygmalion dans laquelle il mis en
examen pour financement illégal de
campagne électorale
guillaume bernard c'est un acharnement
contre l'ancien président république
c'est évidemment extrêmement délicat de
prendre position étant donné qu'on n'a
pas les éléments du dossier
maintenant c'est vrai que l'on n'a pas
été très habitués jusqu'à ces derniers
temps avoir des personnalités politiques
aussi poursuivi avec des incriminations
susceptible de conduire à des
condamnations qui soit aussi grave et
c'est vrai que voilà on peut peut-être
effectivement se dire que l'arrivée au
compte gouttes de ces différentes mises
en examen pourraient signifier une
volonté délibérée de mise à mort
définitive de ce personnage politique
mais cela dit il est bien évident que ne
disposant pas des éléments du dossier et
nicolas sarkozy en lui même cet
après-midi dit que pour par secret de
l'instruction il ne divulguerait pas les
pièces bon on va écouter on peut quand
même difficilement se promènerait se
prononcer sur la chose la question alors
on vous demande pas de vous prononcer
sur le fond parce que par définition
effectivement on l'a pas nicolas sarkozy
a été entendu pendant quatre jours comme
vous l'avez rappelé il s'est exprimé via
un texte sur les réseaux sociaux via
facebook et twitter pour clamer son
innocence ferghana diaries vous vous
pensez vous que c'est un acharnement de
la justice l'ancien mais là encore je
vais vous décevoir parce que je fais
botté en touche en vous disant que je
n'en sais absolument rien puisque pour
parler d'acharnement il me faudrait il
faudrait je sois capable d'évaluer
la qualité d'aidé faisceau d indices et
aujourd'hui des présomptions qui pèse
sur nicolas sarkozy
je reste pour la prison son innocence
évidemment et nicolas sarkozy a lui-même
été finalement assez confiant ce genre
dans sa déclaration en disant que la
vérité et la justice et triomphera et
que son innocence finira par être établi
définitivement donc il ya même dit
pardon j'ai regardé il a même dit je
prouverai mon innocence
ce qui pour le coup ne paraît pas de je
dirais totalement d'une efficacité
enfin d'une d'une dune ne traduirait pas
pour le coup le fait qu'il soit
véritablement sûr de lui pourquoi parce
que normalement
6 il n'y a pas véritablement de faisceau
d'indicés
il devrait dire c'est la charge de
l'accusation la charge de la preuve
incombe à la cotisation et donc ils ne
peuvent rien prouvé mais on sent bien
qu'il est quand même assez fébrile parce
que il se dit que il faut qu'il aille
jusqu à prouver son innocence pour être
dédouanés et de des raids et des
accusations vis-à-vis de l'opinion
publique
voilà je sais pas si j'ai été super mais
là le fameux les utiliser cette
expression la trouvaient simplement au
mauvais qu'il est quand même un peu
fébrile il ya un point pour lui me
semble-t-il notamment quand il dit que
voilà ce qu ils l'accusent ou ceux dont
on tire les informations sont peut-être
des personnages un peu interlope
il semblerait qu'effectivement il est
plutôt raison cela dit dans le milieu
politique il y a aussi des personnages
un peu interlope donc voilà il faut
pondérer tout ça oui et on rappelle que
sur d'autres à faire que ça soit leur
stream ou la ferme est en cours soit il
a bénéficié d'un non lieu soit il n'a
pas été mis en examen donc pour le coup
il peut s'appuyer là dessus pour
renvoyer les décisions judiciaires
ça veut dire que les éléments à charge
contre moi que les éléments à décharge
donc c'est une vraie décision judiciaire
prise par un juge d'instruction
magistrat du siège donc c'est pas
simplement un arrêt des poursuites et
politiquement ce qui est intéressant
c'est de voir les réactions
je vous propose d'écouter celles de
julien aubert député du vaucluse qui est
allé monter sur bfm tv en défense de
nicolas sarkozy les mots font mal parce
que malfaiteurs pour un ancien président
de la république
c'est une accusation grave qui
d'ailleurs alimente toujours le
sentiment du tous pourris
chez les citoyens donc c'est une
accusation très grave et je peux
comprendre la stupéfaction du nicolas
sarkozy qui depuis près de dix jours
maintenant victime je dirais le toute
une série de procédures qui le meut qui
mêle son nom et qui en même temps on
n'aboutit jamais c'est un peu une fois
on dit souvent gouvernement des juges
les juges qui veulent prendre le pouvoir
sur les politiques vous avez cette
impression là haut au delà de la sphère
sarkozy d'ailleurs honnêtement ce que je
trouve assez assez déroutant en français
que tout le monde y la justice est
indépendante mais personne sans d'y
croire c'est à dire que
le garde des sceaux actuelle mais ce duo
moretti a lui-même bâti son image de
marque sur une critique acerbe de la
magistrate yves de la magistrature
notamment les juges du parquet nicolas
sarkozy leur site parle d'acharnement
judiciaire laisse ici entendre qu' on
aurait une magistrature en réalité
politisé et aux services d'un agent des
particuliers mais moi je le pose la
question à savoir parce que ces gens là
ont été au pouvoir ils ont aussi dans ce
cas là était dans la position entre
guillemets d'utiliser notre magistrature
si il part du principe que la
magistrature est inféodée au pouvoir
politique
donc moi je m'interroge quand même deux
sur l'attitude de cette de cette
opposition qui s'est émue d'une
magistrature qui serait possiblement
entre les mains d'un complot mais dans
ce cas là pourquoi son sa réforme n'a
pas été mise sur la table le plus tôt
pourquoi on attend d'être dans
l'opposition à chaque fois pour
critiquer la magistrature pourquoi
lorsqu'on n'est pas aux affaires on ne
prend pas ce problème à bras le corps si
tant est qu'il y avait un problème
d'indépendance de la magistrature dans
ce pays
donc moi c'est 72.2 deux mesures qui me
pose problème puisque la magistrature
chaque camp se plaît à critiquer lorsque
lorsqu'il n'est pas pouvoir ce qui pose
une question d'impartialité parce que
ces gens là jouent avec le feu ils vont
finir par imposer le discrédit sur ce
qui est un pilier de notre est adroit et
six personnes venaient ne ne croit en la
neutralité d'une institution qui est
censé être au dessus des partis
je donne pas cher de notre culture
constitutionnelle à long terme est ce
que vous répondez à faire car notre
super gars nazeri
jeffrey référence à ce qu'a dit un jour
jean denis bredin qui est peu suspect
d'être de droite et droit n'a pleuré a
comme moi bon mais je la trouve
parfaitement quand il disait ça en fait
la magistrature et techniquement
juridiquement constitutionnellement
indépendante mais ajoutait-il
il faut à tout prix qu'elle arrive à se
rendre aussi indépendante de son
idéologie
or il est bien évident que on a tout un
ensemble de magistrats notamment du je
dirais à la formation que ces gens là
ont reçu notamment à l'école nationale
de la magistrature à bordeaux
ce qui fait que ils ont une orientation
idéologique et qu' ils peuvent se
peut-être se servir et bien des moyens
dont il dispose
qui sont normalement au service de
l'ordre public au service de la justice
eh bien peut-être pour privilégier
certaines certaines enquêtes ou
certaines certaine orientation plutôt
que plutôt que d'autres donc oui je
pense qu'effectivement il y a on peut
parfaitement et avoir un doute je dirais
sur l'indépendance non pas technique
mais la dépendance idéologique de cette
magistrature même techniquement dupond
moretti est arrivé avec sa fonction en
disant je vais déposer une réforme de la
magistrature donc que quand quelqu'un
dit je vais déposer une réforme pour
rendre la magistrature indépendante ou
tout cas plus indépendante
il sait dire qu'il sous-entend
implicitement qu'elle ne l'est pas
actuellement alors il faut t-il entre
eux et faut-il vraiment qu'elles le
soient c'est à dire que par exemple est
ce que le rôle du parquet ça n'est pas
de mener une politique au service de
ceux qui ont été élus et d'ailleurs aux
états unis le parquet le district
attorney et élus pour mener une certaine
politique pénale
donc moi je l' ai déjà une île n'est pas
dépendant du pouvoir exécutif via sud et
bien sûr et donc pourquoi ne pas revenir
alors parce que on pousserait des hauts
cris
moi je ne suis pas parti forcément
partisans c'est le moins que l'on puisse
dire des mesures révolutionnaires mais
pourquoi ne pas revenir aux dispositions
de 1791 et de proses et de proposer les
élections mais l'élection des magistrats
alors ça c'est un autre débat mais
passionnant aussi sur le
la question qu'on a posés avez vous le
sentiment que la justice s'acharne sur
nicolas sarkozy
les internautes sont plus tranchés 73%
ce que oui pense que oui vous aviez un
j'avais un pressentiment être
effectivement sur ceux qui regardent le
figaro s'est arrêté aux pensées ya quand
même une chose pardon je voulais je fais
là non alors attendez père dont je me
suis trompé
ces noms n'ont envoyé à céder un procès
d'intention et le pardon
les jeux c'est moi qui avais induire en
erreur on avez vous le sentiment que la
justice s'acharne contre nicolas sarkozy
non à 73%
donc effectivement voilà ils sont c'est
qu'il ya un sentiment effectivement je
dirais de désabusement de perte de
confiance vis-à-vis du personnel
politique qui est qui et qui est
incontestable il est possible aussi que
dans cette réponse il y est la déception
d'un certain nombre d électeurs de
nicolas sarkozy de 2007 qui était
enthousiaste et il a été très bien élu
et avec un véritable enthousiasme et qui
ont considéré que le mandat qu'il a
menée notamment par son intervention en
libye parce qu'ils amendent peuvent ne
pas passer ça sous silence le mandat
qu'il a menée et bien les a les a déçus
il ya une autre chose qui mériterait
aussi d'être évoquée c'est que on est
quand même en train d'ici de débattre
alors il yal'affaire bygmalion galles
affaires de la libye de financement
occulte de campagne électorale je
rappelle quand même que on a voté à
partir de 1995 des lois pour mettre en
place le financement public se dire
prendre de l'argent encore une fois aux
électeurs c'est le libéral qui aurait dû
dire ça prendre de l'argent aux
électeurs en particulier lors du premier
tour des élections législatives
1 voix une voix égale entre 0 et 20 2
euros pour le parti politique et on voit
on constate qu'à l'évidence cela n'a
absolument pas empêché le prix des
campagnes d'augmenter et le fait qu'il y
ait des recours à des financements
occultes
donc non seulement il ya des
financements occultes vraisemblable mais
en outre les contribuables comptes donne
un fonds de roulement partis politiques
je crois que là on est arrivé
effectivement à une situation qui peut
parfaitement écoeuré nos contemporains
on le dit souvent chaque fois qu'il ya
une affaire sur nicolas sarkozy mais
vous pensez que celle-ci cette mise en
examen c'est un coup d'arrêt à une
ambition politique citant tech qu' il
pouvait en avoir une pour la prochaine
présidentielle
oui pour moi alors sincèrement à partir
du bon c'était déjà très difficile pour
lui de revenir à la primaire de 2016 et
planer sur lui le syndrome vge
c'est à dire un président de la
république qui s'est représenté et qui a
été battu ils n'arrivent pas à revenir
présidentiable et donc c'est sans lui
est arrivé en 2016 honnêtement ça plus
toutes ces mises en examen ça le val
vraisemblablement absolument l'empêcher
d'être susceptibles d'être candidats en
ça me paraît assez assez évident il a
déjà deux dates je vais rappeler tout à
l'heure fin novembre premier procès en
mars 2021 un deuxième procès est ici si
jamais les juges décident de construire
et et de poursuivre évidemment ça veut
dire que 2021 ou 2022 un nouveau procès
vous pensez vous que je ne suis pas sûr
que ça suffise à arrêter ses ambitions
premièrement déjà de la droite n'a pas
de figure aujourd'hui personne ne
personne aujourd'hui ne semble au près
avec un pause pour prendre le leadership
de la droite donc lui il va profiter
aussi de ce chaos pour essayer de
s'imposer comme étant le l'ultime
recours de la droite et puis
deuxièmement on vit quand même dans une
société où la défiance envers les
institutions est très forte et le la
sphère fillon je pense n'a pas aidé je
crois à redorer le blason aussi de
l'état droit parce que beaucoup
d'électeurs de droite sont convaincus
que la magistrature pour le coup est
très politisée exerce un deux poids deux
mesures ce qui pourrait tenter nicolas
sarkozy de jouer la carte populiste anti
establishment anti état profond
anti-gouvernement déjuger
essayez donc de défier la magistrature
en faisant de cette défiance un argument
de campagne
donc je pense que politiquement et il
lui reste encore la possibilité de jouer
cette carte pour s'imposer
médiatiquement ce sont les électeurs qui
ne finit trancheront ça fait c'est ce
qui est assez comme vous le disiez
l'ailer n'ayant pas de figure de leader
qui s'impose est évident ça les arrange
pas on voit bien d'ailleurs toutes les
réactions de soutien qui sont vite
apparues mais c'est une pas une pierre
encore dans de plus dans le jardin des
républicains bien sûr la seule chose
c'est que pour que nicolas sarkozy
puisse envisager de revenir
encore faudrait-il qu'il est un
positionnement clair le positionnement
qu'il avait eu en 2007 avec ce qu'on a
appelé la fameuse ligne buisson lui
avait permis effectivement de siphonner
le front national de l'époque et elle
lui avait permis de d'élargir le spectre
politique
ce qui ne semble plus véritablement a
priori en capacité de faire aujourd'hui
c'est plutôt mon analyse en revanche il
est certain qu'il y à un espace
politique
oui mais qui ne serait pas mais qui pour
l'instant n'est pas occuper cet espace
politique de ce qu'on appelait la droite
hors les murs entre l'al aile droite de
l air et puis l'est le dire go show en
tout cas plutôt les modérés du front
national là il ya un espace politique
qui n'est qui est en friche et qui n'est
toujours pas occupé alors je rajoute un
dernier sujet si vous si vous
l'autorisez parce que on a appris cette
semaine que françois sureau est devenue
immortelle
il a été élu à l'académie française et
pas une petite élection 19 fois et sur
27 au premier tour sans croissant
bulletins blancs ce qui je crois est
assez rare c'est ça ce n'est pas arrivé
depuis
puis dix ans c'est mérité pour vous
cette immense élan vous nous posez des
questions difficiles aujourd'hui à
prendre position à bas le principe de
pointer jeu
c'est la deuxième fois qu'il se
présentait donc je suppose qu
effectivement cette fois ci on a
considéré qu'il avait atteint une
maturité une visibilité une place je
dirais dans le monde intellectuel qui
méritait cela moi franchement pour ne
pas vous cacher les choses c'est
malheureusement un écrivain qui est
récemment décédé que j'aurais souhaité
voir halak et midi à l'académie
française c'est jean raspail
alors évidemment c'est vrai que je me
sens plus proche de la sensibilité des
commandes ird et des problématiques d
des envolées mais comment dire de cet
écrivain plutôt que de celle de sureau
mais il va sans dire qu'évidemment c'est
une institution importante qui remonte
au xviie siècle et qui au delà même je
dirais de deux d'avoir eu en son sein
des personnalités a à mon sens
essentiellement pour rôle de maintenir
et de transmettre et donc à la limite
que tous les membres de l'académie
française ne soit pas des personnalités
extraordinaires je ne dis pas que c'est
pas le cas la menace en revanche les
qu'elle soit en revanche chargé
justement de maintenir et de transmettre
c'est ça son rôle moi c'est vrai que on
a eu quand même récemment un certain
nombre de décès à la cabine française je
pense alain de pau quelqu un qui était
pour moi dans mon enfance quelqu'un qui
m'a énormément apporté
je crois beaucoup de français ferghana
ziari l'élection de françois sureau ça
doit être formé là pour vous l'avez bol
d'air frais et puis surtout il avait
fait des textes sur la libéralisation je
trouve ça je salue cette décision de
l'académie c'est à dire que en ces temps
troublés où la liberté est à ce point
mal traités relativiser à la fois par
les gouvernements mais surtout par
l'opinion publique parce que je pense
que ce sont davantage les français qui
ont poussé l'état prend des mesures qui
ne lui ont pas particulièrement plaisir
on a là un défenseur de la liberté qui
en plus le fait avec brio avec une
éloquence sans commune mesure dont moi
je le félicite que cette figure soit de
plus en plus présente dans la sphère
médiatique des actuels et littéraire on
aura besoin de sa voix de son éloquence
dans la défense des libertés publiques à
à l'heure où aujourd'hui les français ne
semblent tout simplement plus croire en
la valeur suprême de la liberté et je
vous rappelle à vous fidèles auditeurs
et téléspectateurs que on a un rendez
vous avec françois sureau mardi prochain
le 20 octobre salle gaveau pour les
fameuses rencontres du figaro et on
s'adapte voilà dit marc on me dit lundi
donc c'est lundi attention lundi 19
octobre donc je ne dise pas de mauvaises
mauvaise date mais surtout on s'adapte
au couvre-feu
comme quoi les salles peuvent s'adapter
et l'horaire si je
on passait bien 18 heures à 18 heures
pour le début des rencontres avec
françois sureau au figaro merci de votre
fidélité
bonne soirée à vous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]